اكبر عدد للجنود الاسرائيليين القتلى منذ
السابع من اكتوبر بعد 108 ايام من القتال
يسقط 21 جنديا اسرائيليا في هجوم واحد
لكتائب القسام على تصريحات المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين تعكس قوه الضربه التي تلقاها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في حربه على قطاع
غزه امس كان من اصعب الايام منذ اندلاع
الحرب لقد فقدنا 24 من خيره ابنائنا الذين
سقطوا دفاعا عن الوطن النبا الاليم الذي
تلقيناه بالامس هو بمثابه ضربه قويه هؤلاء
هم جنود الاحتياط الذين تركوا كل شيء
للدفاع عن دوله اسرائيل وحمايه الرؤيه
الصهيونيه وفق اعلان كتائب القسام فانه
عند الساعه الرابعه من عصر يوم الاثنين
الثاني والعش من يناير الجاري في عمق 600
متر من السياج الفاصل بين غزه واسرائيل
شرق مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع كان الجنود
الاس اسرائيليون يفخخ مباني فلسطينيه ضمن
سياسه خلق منطقه عازله داخل القطاع بعد
الانتهاء من تفخيخ مبنيين استهدف مقاتلوا
القسام دبابه ميركافا بقذيفه ياسين 105
فتم
تدميرها بالتزامن مع ذلك استهدف مقاتلو
القسام احد المبنيين اثناء وجود الجنود
داخلهما انفجرت القذيفه المضاده للافراد
وانفجرت معها الالغام التي وضعها الجنود
الاسرائيليون لتدمير المباني سقط المبنيان
على 21 جنديا قتلوا جميعا بقذيفه واحده
وانسحب
المنفذون يفيد تحقيق الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين ظهروا فجاه من بين
الحقول واقتربوا عشرات الامتار ثم تمكنوا
من الفرار لكن الاهم في هجوم القسام ان
القتلى الوا هم من قوات الاحتياط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينقسم الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
قوات نظاميه واخرى احتياطيه تضم القوات
النظاميه بحسب التقديرات
173000 جندي بينما تضم قوات الاحتياط اكثر
من
465 ال جندي جنود الاحتياط هم جنود سابقون
انتهت مده خدمتهم الالزاميه النظاميه
فقرروا الخدمه في قوات الاحتياط عند
الحاجه اليهم هؤلاء ايد عامله في السوق
الاسرائيلي اي انهم موظفون وفنيون ومختصون
في مجالات المختلفه في مؤسسات الدوله في
الوضع الطبيعي يستدعى جنود الاحتياط من 30
الى 60 يوما في السنه لابقائها في حاله
اقل فاعليه من الناحيه العسكريه الا انهم
اكثر تاثيرا في المجالات اللوجستيه للجيش
والمجالات الاقتصاديه في البلاد لذلك تعمد
قياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لابعادهم عن قوات
راس الحرب حتى لا تقع فيهم خسائر كبيره
وبالتالي يخسر اقتصاد قوه عامله كان صوت
جنود الاحتياط عاليا ومسموعا في عده مفاصل
تاريخيه في اسرائيل لقد كانوا احد الاسباب
التي اقنعت الحكومه بالانسحاب من لبنان
عام 85 وكانوا احد الاسباب المهمه التي
دفعت رئيس الحكومه اسحاق رابين للذهاب نحو
اتفاق اوسلو عاقب الانتفاضه الاولى عام 93
وهم ابناء النساء الاسرائيليات التي شكلن
حركه الامهات الاربع عام 97 ومارسنا ضغطا
كبيرا على الحكومه للانسحاب من جنوب لبنان
عام 2000 تلك الخسائر في الاحتياط في هذه
المراحل التاريخيه كانت وراء قرارات
الحكومه للانسحاب من لبنان وهاء الفا
الاولى بالذهاب الى اتفاق
اوسلو هكذا تكون الضربه قاسيه ويكون اليوم
ثقيلا على اسرائيل ليس على الجيش وحده بل
على صاحب القرار العسكري
[موسيقى]
والسياسي